bonjour l'auteur ça va salut maroni
alors aux sources à voir aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je vais faire découvrir le
dispositif que l'on appelle la bourse
départementale une aide financière du
département pour permettre à nos jeunes
l'accès à l'enseignement supérieur tout
état pour les étudiants allons retrouver
louane une jeune étudiante qui va nous
en dire plus ok vous aussi la bourse
départementale ça vous intéresse alors
suivez-moi
[Musique]
la bourse départementale c'est une aide
financière attribuée à de jeunes
réunionnais sur critères de ressources
familiales pour effectuer leurs études
supérieures de bac + 1 à bac + 5 alors
racontez nous comment fonctionne ce
dispositif la bourse départementale et
une aide financière calculée en fonction
des revenus de nos parents une fois le
dossier complété et validée nous
recevoir un premier versement à la
rentrée et puis en second versement à la
fin du premier semestre et quelles sont
les conditions à remplir pour bénéficier
de cette bourse les conditions à mon
père et qu'il faut déjà respecter les
critères d'admission mais il faut
principalement être assidu en cours est
envoyé par la suite son bulletin de
notes et qu'est ce qui vous plaît dans
ce dispositif ce qui me plaît et comme
je ne peux pas concilier travail études
c'est une aide en plus pour mon loyer
les charges mais fournitures scolaires
ou encore mes courses merci douanes
merci
[Musique]
la bourse départementale est accordée à
treize mille étudiants réunionnais issus
des milieux les plus modestes et les
versions début de cursus et à la fin du
premier semestre sous réserve d'une
bonne progression de l'étudiant dans son
cursus de son assiduité aux cours et de
sa présence aux examens alors dites nous
qui peut bénéficier de la bourse
départementale alors pour bénéficier de
labour départemental il faut être
étudiant et correspondent aux critères
de ressources plafonnées à 86 mille
euros donc le dispositif est composé de
cinq échelons dont les montants varient
de 375 euros à 1250 euros pour des
études à la réunion et 2550 à 2150 euros
pour un étudiant réunionnais qui
souhaitent effectuer ses études en
métropole ou dans l'union européenne et
quand sont prévues les inscriptions pour
bénéficier de la bourse départementale
dans les inscriptions sont possibles du
30 avril au 31 décembre mais le plus tôt
sera le mieux le paiement intervient
dans un second temps après transmission
du dossier par l'étudiant pris en charge
par un gestionnaire qui validera le
dossier complet et la durée moyenne d'un
traitement du dossier et de vingt jours
après sa transmission est ce que tous
les étudiants peuvent bénéficier de
cette aide alors non c'était deux
réservés aux étudiants un cursus initial
donc ceux qui s'inscrivent en parcours
professionnel comme un engin en
alternance par exemple ne seront pas
éligibles et également ceux qui
s'inscrivent en filières paramédicales
social merci minutes mais merci
alexandre
la bourse départementale a été mise en
place pour faciliter la poursuite des
études supérieures de nos jeunes aussi
bien à la réunion qu au sein des pays de
l'union européenne le but est d'avoir
une jeunesse réunionnaise former et
diplômer prête à s'investir en faveur du
développement et du rayonnement de notre
département
si vous souhaitez avoir plus
d'informations sur la bourse
départementale
n'hésitez pas vous avez toutes les
coordonnées qui s'affiche sur votre
écran
le département des générations c'est
fini si vous souhaitez revoir cet
épisode ainsi que les précédents rendez
vous sur nos sites et nos réseaux
sociaux quant à moi je vous retrouve
très vite pour un nouvel épisode à
bientôt
la semaine prochaine nous irons à la
rencontre d'un médaillé paralympique
dimitri parade et unifiée de l'aide de
sportifs de haut niveau un petit coup de
pouce du département pour
l'épanouissement des sportifs
réunionnais en haut niveau
[Musique]